you could go down alleyways anywhere the
city you're going to find wild food I
mean literally everywhere there are
things that are very tasty very
palatable you can't possibly get fresher
food my name is Christopher new yesh and
I'm the founder of the school of
self-reliance I study the uses of plants
and I teach city people how to use them
if I lived in those we pick Ford's maybe
for mushrooms my whole life I've been
interested in the outdoors
it's always been my love to feel more
self-reliant so I'm happy to be able to
do that Los Angeles really is a good
place to forge the fringes of parks the
edges of gardens the edges of farms I'm
a very fast efficient harvester I'll
take a bag in the ninth period I have a
mental map I know where there's a lot of
this and I need that I could go there in
the heart of LA yeah there's little
pockets all over people who have
gardeners as soon as the weeds come up
they cut them down that's the biggest
obstacle for me regularly collecting
wild food the challenge is in the way we
view the so called weave these are some
of the most nutritious plants on the
face of the earth and yes there are
things that may be different than what
you're used to eating so we collected
mustard flowers radish flowers pods and
leaves mallow fruits and leaves yucca
flowers purslane and lambsquarters
leaves it's just what I do as part of my
normal diet I do it because I just like
doing I like the idea of making
something from seemingly nothing
I could make a meal from just things
that I've gone out and collected I can
make fire with sticks to me that's very
empowering in a way even if I never have
to do it I'm going to do a loop on each
end what I do on my classes we're going
to take people out and we're going to
actually see the plants in the field
let's see what we have over here I get
people from all walks of life who come
to these classes some want something
that's more nutritious some are the
survivalist some want just a different
experience of food the foodies I'm not
in the position to solve the world's
problems but I'm in a position to convey
to individuals new choices that they can
make so I'm happy to pass that along to
others it's an amazing feeling
[Music]